hello and welcome to say you're playing
call / b this.a been sick or pass as a
gariand player i'm not sure this is some
relation so not it's italian flag right
not yeah okay so i'm playing this this
line again this system Yemen going for
some development and see what what I get
really looks like black it's just play
like in the Italian game yeah what now
Bishop out and could be a bit neither
know ok let's do it that is to take on
deform play 90 forward ok he's
preventing this by just going 95 himself
I can't i think i'm going to take this
guy is pretty high rated by the way
usually you you know players with that
high and a rating but not in this case
ok night takes d5 he will take with the
sea polis is not very attractive ok i
can go see six
hmm
we should be for it that's very
important and not very very nice okay
very nice but i probably don't get any
more here okay let's do it okay this
ending this ending is not much fun but I
have to try to be a good defender here
yeah this is what I kind of expected I
wasn't I wasn't sure how good it is to
be honest I probably is pretty good for
black okay so i have to be quite quite
modest here if i win they pawned if i
get the apron I'm i will play 3 against
4 and draw this I guess well maybe I'm
not getting this this is this is this
would be bad
maybe maybe I'm not getting this in the
first place yeah it's not it's not nice
at all very uncomf dome yes he five was
my hope here that I know that some
counterplay he takes a group before this
is a draw pretty straightforwardly okay
i still have two defenders but it should
should be it should be at all okay if i
go see for King deform it doesn't do
much good I can check HERE kingly five
and take g4 and age for whom not sure
that this will draw
okay still doesn't have a clear threat
kinky three maybe I cannot lower this
can be three can climb King III is good
no it doesn't do it
time morning check requesting as king at
five oh wow
without the eight points it's a draw but
with the eight points I have my doubts
and there are some time issues quite
clearly with this exact this is are the
things that costs the game without
without the airport this is happening
okay now i was i was praised all homes
just just I was just worse even I
thought still I don't think I should use
the endgame is I simply refuse to
believe that there should be some way to
trade off the Queen side against the
airport draw I don't don't don't believe
it is there some way to do that maybe
there isn't I mean if this is not
possible what I'm talking about is that
if i can trade those three against a two
point i'm drawing this pretty easily the
four against three is the draw but i
don't i don't get the school I don't get
this going he always gets this in and
this is well this is actually doing the
trick right no not at all there they can
do this no that's not a draw ok then I
have to play it differently I mean this
is not so bad this ending maybe a five
then has three goats c5 this c2 I know
my pawn structure is terrible there are
those drawing endings that I could that
I can maybe reach and probably I don't
get them I probably don't get down
yeah I knew that this is not leading to
a super attractive position Bishop
before but I still thought I should hold
it Jim it's probably very difficult this
may be set more precise okay here i can
try this kind of defense but they still
can go here right oops this one maybe
maybe this is something that i can hold
the double pole is not such a big d on
the progress the week queenside you get
to see 5 and so quickly
I don't get this it I don't get to trade
those is really the problem I cannot get
any common to play at all it's just it's
just absolutely rotten and you simply
never he never takes on c5 Jesse or now
he could hear because yes is this king i
DNT m'sieu clunked a little bit i don't
have moves I can do this but he just
plays a king to deform and here i'm
running out of moves I probably cannot
hold this ending I know that it looks
bad but you know this is really a draw
if I can get get those those for traded
but I simply don't manage even though
I'm three against one this was my
drawing idea but I cannot get it to work
you simply cannot okay nice and gamer
white thanks for watching